it's baseball season again and that
means that some San Lots stadiums the
great face-off between pitcher and
batter is back there are lots of pitches
a pitcher can throw but every pitcher is
judged on their fastball and the
fastball is the best pitch in the game
and baseball and that's because a heater
thrown with precision is really really
hard to hit everyone has a fastball and
it's the pitch that gets thrown the most
the very fastest throws 105 miles per
hour and that can be havoc at the plate
batting legend Ted Williams once said
hitting a fastball is the single most
difficult thing to do in sports and he
was probably right
batters barely have time to see and
swing at the ball before it reaches home
plate they should not be able to hit the
damn ball you see the interesting issue
and there are more and more guys
throwing harder and faster in 2008 only
18 pitchers were throwing triple-digit
bass balls and they collectively through
196 of them by 2017 there were 40
pitchers throwing that fast and they
together through 1017 fast balls at or
above 100 miles per hour but what if the
fastball got even faster today we're
gonna look at why throwing and hitting a
110 mile per hour fastball is almost
impossible to find out what it takes I
threw my fastest fastball with a
scientist who's been studying pitching
for decades
I tried hitting a former big leaguers
pitch and stepped into the virtual world
to bat against a superhuman pitching
avatar nope let's start with the pitch
baseball fans had long been thrilled by
the pure speed of the fastball take time
to demonstrate his cannon ball delivery
before radar guns Army Ordnance
equipment had to be brought in to
measure pitch speed rockets along a
world record
[Music]
legends like Bob Feller and Nolan Ryan
through incredible fast balls that left
batters marina today's marvels of the
mound also slim serious speed at the top
of the radar gun is Yankees relief
pitcher Aroldis Chapman who was once
clocked throwing a stunning 105
mile-per-hour fastball he pitches an
average of 101 miles per hour
and last year threw over 345
triple-digit basketballs alright so what
does it actually take to throw a ball
that fast
I talked to Glenn fly sig one of the
world's leading authorities on pitch
mechanics so do we have any sense of
what is distinguishing people who have a
range that Peaks out at 100 miles + is
there something different about them
physiologically proportionally
height-wise yeah that's one of the cool
things about baseball the answer is no
they tend to be tall there are some guys
who are 6 feet who are throwing faster
than the guys were 6 foot 10 fly sig
uses motion capture software to map and
correct throwing mechanics but that
doesn't mean just anyone can hurl heat
you and I do everything right we're not
gonna throw a hundred miles per hour
maybe your range is you're gonna throw
between 70 and 80 miles per hour and
someone else's ranges is there gonna be
throw between 90 and 100 all we could do
with proper mechanics is get you to the
top of your range so I asked fly sig who
works with pitchers from Little League
all the way up through the majors to
look at my mechanics the energy has now
gone up your body the arm is in the
cockpit position what I see here is your
arm does not have enough what we call
external rotation at the shoulder
meaning if I drew a vertical line up
your trunk I would want your forearm to
be perpendicular to that to make a an L
shape so I'd want your hand to be much
lower maybe a foot lower so your arm is
cocked back more even with Glenn's
advice
I was only throwing about half the speed
of the pros so what is the outer limit
in terms of velocity leaving the hand of
today's pitchers the top pitchers have
always been about 100 miles per hour and
I think that is the limit one hundred
hundred five miles per hour I think that
thing that could change is the average
velocity could go up because more guys
can optimize and maximize himself and
get to that limit but fly success
there's been a price
for such speed there are more injuries
and part of the problem is that more
pitchers are throwing at top velocity
and constantly throwing a top velocity
and the body could only take so much he
and his colleagues measured the force
required to actually rupture elbow
ligaments turns out it's actually the
same force that a pitcher puts through
his arm when throwing at top speed you
every time you go back and forward is
about a hundred millimetres here and
here a hundred Newton meters is the
equivalent of holding 512 pound bowling
balls so imagine I hung sixty pounds
from your hand but that's about the
equivalent of what's happening on your
elbow or shoulder at that incident that
force makes for tiny tears in the
ligaments and over time a pitcher who
throws too hard too often is basically
throwing his arm off phytic says that
fast ball mania has led to a jump in
Tommy John procedures that's the surgery
to repair torn ligaments in the elbow he
says that is the limiting factor for
fast ball speed and I know be very
exciting to see the limits break like
for other sports where the ceiling keeps
going up up I think we're at the ceiling
that the ligaments and tendons can't
take it so why do pitchers even bother
throwing that hard because a well-placed
fastball is the gold standard for
striking out batters to understand what
a batter is up against you have to look
at this incredibly short period of time
that they have to decide if a ball is
even worth swinging at it's 60 feet six
inches from the pitcher's mound to home
plate but the actual distance is shorter
the pitcher releases the ball about 55
feet from the plate and a fastball
moving 100 miles per hour takes about
four tenths of a second to make that
trip and here's the thing it takes 50
milliseconds for the iron brain to even
register the pitch another hundred and
fifty milliseconds to swing the bat that
leaves just a split second for the
batter to decide if the pitch is worth
swinging at the batter has to pretty
much make his decision within 200
milliseconds that's why some people var
good batters should not be able to do it
I can tell you that it is incredibly
difficult a little bit I went to
Villanova University where Kevin movil
who was the baseball coach there and a
former pro pitcher himself
a few fast balls passed me I made
contact twice I was just concentrating
on keeping the ball away from him I
didn't want to hit you I didn't want to
come inside I didn't want to get
anywhere near you which I appreciated he
was throwing in the 80s and was
incredibly consistent but here at
Villanova
they've got a tireless pitcher who can
throw everything from high school speeds
right up to the truly impossible there
nailed it so I am inside the cave at
Villanova and right now it's a virtual
batter's box inside a virtual stadium
and I'm hitting against a virtual
pitcher who can throw any style of pitch
we want he can throw a changeup he can
throw a fastball I can throw a curveball
or a slider he can even do impossible
pitches but no actual bats allowed this
screen alone costs fifty thousand
dollars engineer mark du Pina created
the system by inputting actual MLB pitch
data so what batters see is a real pitch
delivered virtually what we're doing
here as much as we can is develop a
training tool and then we're also
looking at to add in eg sensors to
measure focus level eye trackers to
properly see how well the eye is moving
with with the ball we're developing
something not only to help the baseball
team but we're getting other scientists
and engineers involved in this this
project Japan I can do things like
freeze the ball midair and have batters
identify the pitch that's gonna be high
yeah high and inside it's harder than it
sounds
but some of Villanova's players took
right to it I was I wasn't right all the
time but it was definitely very
beneficial to try to pick up and really
focus in on arm recognition and where
the slot of the ball is coming out of it
strike fastball and we can even show you
what realistically a hundred and twenty
mile an hour fastball would look like I
tried one of those nope
121 121 miles per hour for psychologist
Jerry long the cave batting simulator
could answer questions about our ability
to track moving objects 121 miles
I agree you could have hit that oh yeah
like is it really true that you've got
to keep your eye on the ball to hit it
what if the ball disappeared after 200
milliseconds the presence of the ball
should almost be unnecessary is that
true I don't know the answer to that I'd
love to find that out I also tried one
of Japan's other creations a hacked
oculus rift that he's rigged so a player
can swing for the virtual fences how the
timing is completely different all right
this is a fast ball moving in 111 miles
per hour fifth or sixth time is the term
finally right yes all right finally so
in the sixth or seventh attempts knowing
exactly when and where this ball is
coming standing way in the back of the
batter's box so that my sweet spot is
perfectly aligned with the incoming
trajectory of this pitch I was able to
make contact with a 111 mile-per-hour
impossibly fast fast ball so will we
ever see a pitch like that in real life
probably not but virtual reality could
help us better understand how batters
track and connect with the ball because
what they're doing now is already almost
impossible